all right so as I promised last week on
my Facebook and Twitter I'm going to
review one of my favourite games which
is also one of the most underrated games
of all time Shadow of the Colossus all
right so I was going to wait for the HD
remix that's coming out for the ps3
before I reviewed this for you guys but
I went to video games live and they
played one of the themes - shadow with
the Colossus and I just couldn't wait
anymore so Shadow of the Colossus is a
pretty simple concept actually in this
faraway land that looks like Peter
Jackson presents Shadow of the Colossus
this young guy brings his chick to this
alters chicks dead blazer down in this
voice from above that sounds like oh boy
pretty much says okay dude I'll bring
back your chick as long as you take out
the 16 colossi who are terrorizing the
world and so that's what you do that is
literally your task you go out and you
take out the 16 colossi you don't level
up your weapons you don't talk to
townspeople nothing boring you go from
the beginning and straight from boss
battle to boss battle to boss battle 16
v 16 bosses 16 puzzles 16 colossi and
it's really cool because yeah there are
puzzles in the game but the Colossus is
the puzzle you go up against these
things you see him and you're like
you're a speck you're nothing that's not
even one of the biggest ones right there
that's one of the smaller ones there are
smaller ones in him there are much
bigger ones than him and you have to
find a way to take these things out you
can't just go in hack in and slash I
mean you're an ant this thing is there
you're here you're that big in
comparison to them you have your
surroundings you have him you have your
sword and you need to use your brain to
figure out how to take them out I'm not
gonna lie there are many times you're
gonna be like I don't know I have no
idea and there are all sorts of
different colossi - there's like big
ones that walk upright ones that walk on
all fours ones that are really fast ones
that fly how do you take out of flying
Colossus really play the game use your
brain you'll find out I'm not one for
game FAQ or like going online and
looking into things I mean I'll do it if
I really crack and I'm like this is did
you just give me the secret get
seriously I like figuring them out but
if they don't matter they don't matter
do not Google how to take these things
out that's like what the game is all
about and what I like is the music the
music really goes with the tone of this
game like when you first meet a colossus
the music's really dreary you don't know
what to do the music absolutely reflects
that and when the game figures out that
you figured out how to take this thing
down you're crawling up is less
grabbing onto his hair and you're just
climbing the music becomes this really
heroic score and this thing knows it's
in deep what's trying to shake you
off you're like this little GI Joe
hanging off is like head in his arm and
you just rev up and you start stabbing
as that is badass dude seriously and you
just know the last thought that goes to
the mind of this Colossus after you take
him down is are you me now dude
this is
I can only compare it to like imagine a
butterfly takes you down that's the same
as you takin down a Colossus coolest
thing is when you see one walking away
and you take your bow and arrow on
blasted atom his back is turned then he
turns around like this and looks at you
sees eyes turn red and you starts
walking towards you you're just like my
life I'm dead and then when you take him
down try to tell me you do not feel like
King Kong and cocaine seriously I'll say
it's one of my favorite games but it's
not meant for everyone it's just not
there are people who will be like this
game's boring all you do is ride a horse
and take out the 16 big-ass beasts and
make you feel like a badass is stupid
where's Master Chief but I will say not
every game has this kind of
recommendation from me if you have a
PlayStation 2 yes Ari Xbox people its
PlayStation exclusive its Sony not only
should you play this game you have to
play the game and the ICO Shadow of the
Colossus combo and HDS coming out for
the PlayStation 3 really soon I've
beaten this game a few times but never
an HD yeah it has to happen I think the
game is probably 1012 hours maybe it
doesn't matter best 10 or 12 hours
you've played and your horse your horse
is a straight-up badass if you're
throwing down with this Colossus you can
call your horse your little horse runs
up starts bucking at the colossi he's
not doing anything to them but the horse
has heart
sorry Epona from Zelda aggro from Shadow
of the Colossus that's my horse I mean
the horse has got to be one of the
greatest supporting characters in games
like period not just pets but like
characters and for a game with no
dialogue that's really saying something
Shadow of the Colossus is the very
definition of epic best I can describe
it and as always if you liked what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
you